[Music]
Grandmaster in residence anything is
just found x+ the center so welcome so
today's puzzles every week we are going
to do a few puzzles and every week we
are going to change the topic so the
topic for today are going to be
combinations which include backgrounds
so now you know to spot first of all
during the game and way to spot the back
ranks
puzzles tactics so how how do we how do
we spotted it we have a few
preconditions to spot them so number one
there is no escape hole so in this case
for example black doesn't have an escape
only sometimes because it we call the
window
we though is it I guess the mole will
popular term because there if there's
fire get out of the window
and the sound South was also escape oh
it's alright so so the second thing is
that we usually spot us the weakness of
the background and which is going to be
Polly
so the age rank or the first threat
witness the back rank is usually we can
spoil it by when somebody is training
his ropes
what about the ropes of also something
that we would like to have is a back is
an open fire okay so usually what
happens is it's out of the ropes or the
Queen's are going to be the ones who are
making on the background so you know to
get them there we need a few open public
files for example D file F file C and B
and so on so if we just lock those the
won't be any
I don't think that we we don't see in
this position right now but usually it's
also going to involve some kind of a
sport okay so let's look at this
position we have a few positions today
this is the first one this is a game
with which was played in 1970
sir chef's he was playing white against
our favorite proper official so in this
position is back to move and yes please
quit before okay and then one so king h1
and queen - f - good excellent ok so
yeah in the game Bobby actually played
going to e3 which is very similar
similar idea king has to go to each one
now obviously we don't take this Bishop
on a three this would be a poison Bishop
in this case we are actually going to
lose all the background by Queen taking
on the face we takes a fatal takes of
eight
but it's a good witch exhibition but yes
the ID is actually Queen f2 it's
sacrificing a quick and now if the Rope
takes the Queen on f2 there is going to
be a checkpoint the game actually
continued but the only one that white
has to g1
any questions so but it easy that's just
how our warm up but yeah usually in this
case we are actually deflecting the
deflection we deflect the rope the
defending group from the first round
[Music]
the best thing well we still cannot you
cannot take the picture which in your
life
actually actually in the game quit
that's exactly what you said yeah so
quickly for strength king h1 okay
alright very good
and that's sort of on the next one okay
so this position was played in the 1959
golden Zinta against Boris Spassky white
to move actually White has opportunity
to win here unfortunately we did not see
that
we made a mistake which led to draw you
have to think about how can white
it was passed by shape f70 things look a
fix
okay cool paintings
the Queen things
workdays and also King things
too many roofs all right well you guys
are correct so f7 is the correct move
which which like Miss do it again so
that is that real takes a real takes f7
and now obviously if the district takes
then that is losing because of windy
that's an easy one but if the Queen
takes f7 you take the Queen yes but this
is not over yet
because the king can take well I have I
have a cheater broken to three points
but what we have the strongest
continuation here
we knew one and rookie what a one then a
tree king g6 I started to attack
once you say three
for a tree you want a tube 22:44 let's
let's let s look at this position after
the whole idea is over how the biggest
rook to e8 and push the pawn so this is
the variation that we kind of looked at
and maybe take maybe leniency for is
winning what people even now that is the
quicker that's more and looks like a
common game that we can win
what will be the best course of action
[Music]
because I check
very nice but and it's a good ad good
trap but I guess I don't have to fall
for H for yes but we do it it's a way
okay so we stop the King takes f7
[Music]
we ain't dreaming close close so the
first time you have to play is quick to
e1 we were very close now if I push a
tree why it's great to play what we need
fine as long as why you're going to take
that to the part that it's going to win
right so black and play rope - they ate
what would be the strongest okay
what's the idea
way to be wired with the idea of Queen
going to Pisa
right yeah so in the game actually like
the white mist this woman f7 and instead
he played so this was my name is Boris
Spassky hey no what's my school's black
Oh
even though checkers there is sometimes
the game ended like this
[Music]
all right next next one is a wound up
now we are actually going to look at the
middle game even in the middle game we
have some back rank tactics so a very
famous structure no this is this is a
very different so why was playing your
soup over gas and there is this was in
1998 let me check that I set up this
correctly actually it is black to move
all right so actually this looks like
wife is a strong attack his bishops all
both looking at the Kings side the Queen
so not so easy for black to play it
looks like he defected above the both of
his knights the position of the King so
think about this dispositions it's a
black so as you can see here again we
can see that why doesn't have any
windows right for his King so the
question is how how do we can the first
ring continue looking I mean if I were
to define the first steps with you know
don't give up
wait before and then yeah so this that's
pretty much that is actually a
counter-attacking on this diagonal and
now the correct rule here for white was
actually annotated edition but actually
just to play Queen to be five this is
the only move that moves the Queen away
and still defends the vision but even
here if you play this move that would be
able to play a six and now to take pity
and then to play 955 and without without
this Bishop why definitely they have
lots of attack on this other side and
it's like successfully defends the King
takes the city phone at the default one
falls of block so in the game why did
she do anything for the people Bishop
Knight takes e4 Queen takes e4 and now
you can see that the first strike is
exposed and now your idea terms of the
play of sacrificing the Queen the Queen
takes before that the whole thing there
okay see what's on mate so the game
continued Queen takes d4 row taste is
more still looks like white is holding
so if white played is only oh well yeah
d3 I think that I can just play would be
one create the whole first rank right so
the game continued the Rope
Bishop to see two good petitions over
here real takes Knight wrote a stroke
very dangerous sometimes to put the
bishops like this one five Bishop d3
and bishops protein C to and blacks
weapon what this so again in the in the
beginning it didn't look like much I
mean I I would bet in the last book what
while it was probably something like
grow page three maybe he was
but it's just a good example for us why
it's a good window okay alright good job
good job I had to figure this out
looks like looks like white is better
right with a 95 and both of the active
active rocks
[Music]
why why was playing on board here from
of the strongest webmaster in Israel by
this yeah when he was at least one up to
the world championship
he has a relative at Washu and he came
in to visit and we came in to visit he's
called the club and said I'm in town can
I do something
[Music]
even work yeah yeah yeah if I would say
one of the biggest differences when you
want to become international master of
Grand Master that was stopped after one
looks like it's yeah so what is the move
Thanks exactly tonight takes on
therefore this is how the game continued
now in the game we just we just took the
night 96 also doesn't work at the Queen
things and if I'm a good change the game
so the game with the in Knight takes
Knight and yes the Queen is going to
this rope swing cannot take the road
take the Queen material
like Mexico to you to win the game
I assume Michael sighing all right
this game was played in New Orleans
1919-20 so I was a hundred years ago and
I was playing a story so it is why some
of the second I think as you can see
looks like white is better right but if
you left to hold and then trust me
let me just make one ho ho baby
something like h6 it's not so easy for
white with
luckily is with his wife this case this
father is so tough to solve because
although black doesn't have a window or
the skate route his eighth rank is very
very well defended and especially in
here okay okay so you guys are correct
the first move is bishop is taking on f6
is it is a little bit counterintuitive
right because they are giving up to AO
bishop what denied now first of all the
funny part is that and the black can
actually take the part it maybe he made
puzzle books that it says that black and
is losing this position now it's it
that's also good for him but how can we
try to win what was the way Queen
GeForce this is looks like it's winning
right real things he 78727 thank you sir
how do you attack
about the background right so if the
King moves we can just take this however
this is actually not working so well so
why is this tick yeah so anyway after we
did the game continued with the bishop
taking on f6 because it was all natural
but even if if that takes to the pawn we
don't have to take a d7 I assume that
white is with all the absolutely like
and I they're working for me tonight
that's for some white square so anyway
so Bishop takes Bishop takes of six
doesn't make any sense fabulous we just
activated his mission it looks like if
we exchange all of our rocks on EA's
then it won't give us anything right
and actually what do you guys think
Isabella here black right just because
yeah well depends on which position a
positions in this in this case David the
bishop is nine squares alright so I give
you a hint the first okay okay so queen
is the okay so the only move the black
could do in this position is play Queen
to be fine
it looks like that is holding yeah so
[Music]
[Music]
while the cupcakes then why is better
actually no because I see one but anyway
the best move for black I can just take
the I don't have amazed when I think
that okay so let's go back this is why a
for just what we need so daddy is
again this is the key the key square he
ate this is the old the whole war is
about the he ate square but right now
the queen is defending their square so
if somehow have to deflect the Queen and
the only move to do that we can take the
Queen if they're looking at the Queen
just the beginning
it's not over yet now darling I have
moved it think about this well yeah you
can you can make a drop so your queen
through to g4 it's actually a nice job
well I can't
[Music]
okay now 27 is there is grateful you can
take the Queen because of the main yeah
so like although there still have the
same defense we compete five again in
control
you can still my queen Sephora so much
it's funny but but why can't play Valley
like h3 you can see that so I can say H
capital H again what a subway I was
giving you one head day but the one it
is was that if white plays h3 black in
action it cannot take a little right now
right so you can take Alito because
they're real things I'm going to show
you it really quickly is my first hand
so this is not winning rook takes and
white pants but apparently all of our
other variations are Queen d7 principle
that it works because it can't take what
we do because we are releasing blacks
blacks row right so we saw that 57 fails
to Queen takes people so we actually
have to make a move to deflect the Queen
deflect the black Queen for me too okay
so
because you have to analyze why is this
the correct rule now what do you know
that nobody can take don't think we take
screen and so on so the only move that
they can do is 25 now the idea was so we
get to the same position we sacrificed
our opponent a to but now the difference
is that the queen is not attacking the
room what do you do so if you can figure
out so you can figure out here
what was the move that you wanted to
play for why
I think so in this case the queen is
controlling the be 5 square 57 spell and
the rule is controlling the 84 square we
had a deal with Queen takes be said that
you just kind of prep them with rook to
e4 to play first
[Music]
you
[Music]